au départ il devait faire des entrées
les chroniqueurs et quand j'ai vu leurs
déguisements surtout celui de matthieu
delormeau vous dérangez pas ne fait pas
d'entrée on va demander aux
téléspectateurs et au public de savoir
en quoi ils sont déguisés parce que moi
je n'ai reconnu personne connaissant les
personnes alors vous vous êtes alors on
va essayer de trouver rien bongo c'est
plus facile mais on sait ce qu'ils sont
déguisés en chanteur des années 80 quand
même 80 82 vous êtes ans à ba
aujourd'hui aujourd'hui
ah ouais alors l arceau tu vas jouer
avec lui ou elle vous êtes moi c'est
plus compliqué à mais toi mais voilà les
maîtres aux coudes à on entrait j'ai
redit bien ans et je vois bien que je
chéris mais qu'est ce que vous êtes en
quoi on est un trio nous amène oui on
est tous à quoi
[Applaudissements]
ah que c'est du gâchis
le public nous regarde de manière très
triste il ça me fait peur là il ya tout
beauté à la parodie couteau après
françois valéry alors non il est pas
quand je vais dire ils ont le même nom
il engage ogada quoi piquer lives et dvd
à lencouacq élevé novelli on adore les
lives et dvd
les 10 vainqueurs
parfois je ne sais quoi
gilles humeau amen
ennjimi moi même à trouver il est
tentant mais moi mais voilà les visages
généralistes aux ménages de la boue
alors vous je ne sais pas du tout qui
loue des larmes ou souhaitant amiel en
quoi c'est pas
diana king dont tu viens hacking diana
qui n'ont nom tribal king tribales qui
disons non plus n'ont sabrina non non
non non non non mais il nous manque
quelque chose
c'est vrai que ce soit aulas innovantes
quelques chouettes je suis avec
christine et en os x on à quoi bon si
c'est en quoi on est en iam tiendra dans
leurs jambes ryan que j'adore aussi la
la moustache
vous êtes ton amiable bah merci alors
bon doc gynéco on a tous su trouver
encore vous étiez larusso
[Musique]
et alors celui alors matthieu delormeau
je vous le dis il est rentré dans ma
loge trou mais impossible de trouver en
qui il est vous avez une minute
larousse ou et nelson monfort pour
trouver en quoi et matthieu delormeau un
chanteur cheb khaled
s'il pensait à metz d'origine ce que
j'aime mon personnage petite série mais
elle a pris en 2000 et ont une histoire
à lire
est invité merci voilà merci aux
costumes à la prochaine fois ils peuvent
venir un petit peu plus tard voilà on
l'est on les appellera pas vous
inquiétez pas